well specifically the 50s and 60s
everything you know post-world war two I
mean everybody was more it was like a
uniform and there was something really
refreshing about that going through this
you know late 60s and 70s more of I
guess everything easing up and you know
the world of you know maybe fighting the
establishment a little bit so in a way
there were all those kind of times that
definitely fashion has changed along
with those times and now I think we're
we're in a time of people having so much
and the resources to be able to buy so
much that there's so many choices out
there which I think sometimes isn't
always the best thing for four people
that thing in a way it does and I think
in a way sometimes that's why when you
look at kids and having school uniforms
i think that's that's probably a really
good idea because i think it's it's in a
way it it takes that that burden and
that preoccupation with for you know
kids that don't have control over what
they actually can buy of thinking really
focusing on what is more important for
them while they're at school i supposed
to really what they're wearing so it
does contribute a little bit too much
you